[Music]
let's go to caleb in fort lauderdale
what's up caleb
hey how's it going how's it going guys
we're good brother what's up dude how
can we help
yeah man so i'm out here for fort
lauderdale florida i'm 21 years old i'm
a dad of a one-year-old i have a
girlfriend i'm running out of an
apartment for about like 1200 dollars
i'm in depth about i want to say um 20
yeah yeah about 20 grand
currently unemployed i've been doing
customer service for like the last three
four years
and really
my general question would be obviously
you know how to get out of debt uh you
know be debt free and i've been having
to do side jobs like uber eats and
you know a couple of
other side jobs whatever i can find to
be able to pay my bills because really
my expenses are more than what i'm
actually making
you're unemployed so you're making
basically zero right
yeah currently yeah i was just
unemployed yes i was laid off yesterday
um so now i'm kind of unemployed today
yeah correct
dude um
i'm sorry that happened that's no good
who who laid you all i mean not who not
the company but where'd you get laid off
from customer service
say that again you got laid off from
your customer service job
all right well
this is a sales position but yeah okay
so
21
girlfriend kid
20 grand in debt just got laid off
and
you woke up today today feels heavy huh
yeah definitely definitely i mean i i've
been kind of watching you guys for a
little bit and uh i was like man i gotta
i gotta give them a call man i just
don't know what to do right now um you
know
yeah yeah
so what
caleb what do you wanna do man
well um currently i mean i've been just
looking for jobs
you know like just moving no no no no no
no yeah i got that i got that what do
you want to do
like like my future my dream job is
you're in a boat that has a big hole in
it and you've got a cup and you're
trying to bail the water out and then
you added a girlfriend then you added a
one-year-old
and then somebody dropped a bigger hole
in that boat and what you're looking
around for is another cup and what i'm
asking you is
what boat do you want to be in man two
years from now five years from now what
do you want this thing to look like down
the road
stability man stability uh i know what
do you want to do free what do you want
to do well i
i would like to become uh a professional
trader i mean that's that's something i
really you know love doing you know
looking at charts and uh things like me
it may not be you know something like
everyone's you know dream or anything
but i'd like to become a professional
trader
a trader trade like a stock trader
yeah correct like sponsorship but yes
yeah i'm really into that
so what steps have you taken to become a
stock trader
well um i've done a lot of studying but
i know the biggest thing is if you want
to make money i mean you kind of have to
have money in order to trade and things
like that and i'm not going to be
borrowing money to trade anything like
that so
i'm trying to essentially be able to
build an account uh with money you know
saving that account so then be able to
go ahead and start trading with little
little small sizes and you know be able
to grow my account uh long term you know
within the next five ten years
so can i be honest with you but yes sir
that's real close to
a get rich scheme
some kind of scam some kind of shortcut
to
try to dig yourself out of the hole that
you're in
now wanting to trade stocks wanting to
be an investment banker all that stuff's
great man
but
when you've got a baby and a girlfriend
in an apartment
and
twenty thousand dollars in debt
trying to build your portfolio over
there on the side you see what i'm
saying
right
so
what what what things do you have here's
man you and i could talk for a while um
here's what i'm worried about i'm
worried about you got a little baby
there you got a scared to death
girlfriend you have rent due
and you got to start figuring out a i
got to get some some money to go pay the
bills right now
whatever that looks like not one job not
two job but three jobs
and at the same time you're gonna have
to build some sort of you said i've been
doing some research
you can't just get on the internet and
google stuff about how to trade stocks
you need to go learn about what that is
you take some finance classes you need
to get in there and learn does that make
sense
right correct
so you've got to get a game plan
together that's going to be
both i need some cash right now which
means i just i got to suck up all my
pride all of it and get after it and i
got to make some stability plans with my
family and i got to start planning for
the future and brother you've got to do
this all at the same time which means
for the next two three four five years
you're gonna be tired you're gonna go to
bed exhausted because you're gonna be
working your butt off you're gonna stay
plugged into that kid you're gonna marry
that girlfriend and you're gonna connect
your family together and you're gonna
start planting some roots
does that sound
exciting does that sound like yeah
that's what i'm talking about or did
that make you be like nah bro i just
need to open an account i can make
trades
no that's because that sounds exactly uh
like what i'd love to do are you
currently day trading and stuff what's
going on on that side no no no
no no no no i haven't i haven't traded a
dollar in my money nothing like that as
of yet
yeah how much cash do you have
what's your cash position do you have
any money
uh probably i mean to be quite honest
about like 800 bucks in my checking
account that's about it okay
so and what kind of debt is this 20 000
uh that's an auto loan uh i think that's
an auto loan and uh
yeah credit card are you underwater on
the auto loan what's the car worth
versus what you owe
uh yeah the car is it's a ford focus i'm
i'm a iowa about like i think like 13 at
13 and it's only worth like nine so i am
a little debt little down i was thinking
i mean i'm not sure if it's a great idea
possibly about turning in the car and
just paying whatever's left on it
and just cause because we do have a
second car that's paid off that you know
it's my girlfriend's mom she gave it to
her yeah i was just thinking about just
sticking
uh i mean at this point dude i'd rather
you take that car um it's it's not worth
a whole bunch of money nine thousand
bucks isn't i mean you're in a mess
right now i'd rather you take that car
and start scratching and clawing so this
time tomorrow you have a job somewhere
you've got a job somewhere to get some
sort of income coming in and then you're
gonna have a second job by the end of
this week and you're gonna start looking
at finance school local community
college classes you're gonna get plugged
in there and you and your girlfriend are
gonna go out and have a planning session
and figure out what tomorrow and next
month the next year is going to look
like